let this quiet weather fool you right
now because within the next
24 to 48 hours we're going to see some
big changes
especially by sunday live look outside a
very
tranquil night tonight but here's what
to expect all right
strong winds sunday through monday and a
polar plunge in temperatures
by monday afternoon cold mornings also
on tap from 40's
to even 30's high 30's in some of the
outskirts of the town in the valley
shower chances are also in the forecast
including
mountain snow if we get those showers
that actually come in here give us some
measurable rain
that will break that record dry streak
that we haven't had
rain since april 20. it's been that long
temperatures at this hour mid 60's for
las vegas henderson
61 65 north las vegas winds are staying
light like we said a fairly quiet night
tonight
but then changes come as early as
tomorrow we'll see clouds
mixed with sunshine through most of the
day a very pleasant morning in the 60s
75 by lunchtime a little warmer tomorrow
at 83 degrees however you'll see the
breezy winds start to pick up as early
as i'd say
midday the stronger winds will come on
sunday and get this
fire weather watches on monday doesn't
mean we're not going to get any rain
we could get a chance of it but then
we'll dry out quickly by monday
and give us an elevated fire danger i'll
have a lot more to talk about
in your most accurate forecast just
minutes away brian
okay